- Let's wrap things up,
everybody with one last super
cute feel good story trending on social.
This is What I'm Liking.
When my kids were toddlers,
I loved watching them discover new things.
I still do and that's
why I can relate to a set
of Dallas parents who
have become obsessed,
with how much their
little girl loves stopping
and smelling the candles.
Just look.
- [Brie] Are you ready
to smell some candles?
- Yes.
- [Brie] Okay.
- [King] Okay.
- [Brie] You don't like that one?
- No.
- Yes.
- [Brie] You like that one?
- That's hysterical.
That's two year old Sunday,
and we have her on the line now,
along with her parents, Brie and King.
They watch on NBC 5 Dallas Fort Worth.
Great to see y'all.
- Can you say hi?
- Oh my Gosh.
How she like is just appalled
by some of those candles.
Like, "how dare you put that in my face."
Brie, how did you figure out Sunday's
strong sensibilities on candles?
- Well, we like to think
it was because of us,
but once Sunday was born,
King and I really wanted to make sure that
we kept our regular date and
something that we've been
doing for years is going to
our favorite candle shop.
So when Sunday was around one,
we started bringing her along,
and she asked to smell the candles too.
And then it wasn't long
after that she realized
that she actually had
preferences for candles.
And she's very consistent.
She really likes warm smells,
spicy smells, like vanilla and cinnamon.
And she does not like clean smells,
overly floral smells or fruity smells.
She'll always say no to those.
- It's true.
It's crazy that the world
needed a candle sniffing baby.
So you're welcome to everyone out there.
- Oh my God, King, you win.
That was amazing.
Well, millions of people
have watched Sunday
smell the candles online,
and now she's going to have
her own candles, right?
- [Brie] Yep.
- Yeah, she is. It's crazy.
We partnered with that
candle shop, Jackson Vaughn.
- I think Justin, you have some, right?
- [King] And they are putting
together Sunday's Best Bundle.
It's the candle number
one and number nine,
and they are phenomenal.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- The number one has notes of eggplant,
of some Cyprus or some basil.
The other one has some Moroccan Neroli,
and some Cyprus as well.
And they smell delicious.
So I hope that you enjoy them.
- I love both.
Thank you.
Number nine might be my favorite.
It's like a little sweeter.
- Yeah, I think so too.
So does Sunday. You agree?
- Thank you so much,
Sunday and Brie and King.
I'm liking y'alls posts right now.
And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor truly unstoppable people
like y'all, just making
really cool stuff like this.
So they're gonna be writing you a check,
for a thousand dollars.
- Oh my God.
- Thank you so much.
- It smells so good.
Oh my God, absolutely.
Well, thank you guys,
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Anthony Anderson, Eliza
Schlesinger, Chef Noah Gluten,
Bobby Johnson and Sam James.
Y'all have a great day and if it's not,
try and change it.